voilà alors terrain s'il l'homme à la
casquette hill du nom de sa femme en
fait il s'appelle mario girotti il est
né à venise
signe particulier dans blanche haleine
fraîche à côté de big bud spencer carlo
perrone berceau lycée ça né à naples un
mec 90 environ 140 kg environ
ex-champion de natation alors la
question vous êtes quasiment ensemble
depuis plus de 25 ans et lorsque vous
vivez en couple
sinon nous ne ferions peut-être pas de
film ensemble
il faudrait qu'un gars qui fasse la
vaisselle mais nous nous sommes étonnés
près de huit ans elle travaillait
ensemble et c'était les ruptures le plus
important de ma vie c'est un graphique
parce que nous avons toujours pensé de
travailler ensemble tous les ânes mais
hélas mes terres les à tunis et je
travaille en italie il donne ça nous
avons pas vu parce que pour faire un
film un ensemble nécessaire un âne
minimum de préparation que le faire
l'apses travail il n'est pas ce pas
combiner pour le faire et cette fois il
est venu et je suis très content roller
fait avec lui il est découvert aussi de
la matière celle il est très loin de la
moyenne du portefeuille d'accord et puis
nous on n'a pas prévu de traducteurs
d'italiens mal j'ai un peu peur une peur
de ma carrière
le besoin alors c'est un cinéma
résolument optimiste que vous faites
il ya toujours un apn comme on dit et
vous jouez toujours les bons jamais les
méchants n'ai pas envie de temps en
temps de retourner votre image les
brewers ça que je fais là méchant c'est
fini le public parce que vous êtes
suffisamment riche vous avez mangé mais
considère moi même résumons par louis
qui les met à terre je suis venu au
cinéma très tard que nous aurait il j'ai
commencé à faire personnage est infernal
terre précise je pardonne moi passer sur
un premier filet public que je le dis
beaucoup de fois même pas ce que j'ai
fait une petit peu idiote dans le film
c'est à dire qu'ils république arrive
avant deux mois avec eux et je veux
faire appeler est il assez comique c'est
une fois j'ai fait au film s'appelait
charlie st cloud
il a cinq films d'ici l'été des régions
il est public et il est fort il permet
il est l'élément il est plaisant c'est
pas possible vous terrain s'il vous
n'avez pas envie de faire autre chose de
descendre de cheval
par exemple de faire tout à fait autre
chose que des westerns et côté le
problème c'est que moi j'adore les
westerns
c'est vraiment un problème pour moi
j'adore ça bon moi j'ai fait j'ai joué
12 atteints de rôle des rôles
dramatiques et cetera mais maintenant le
public il aime voir dans ces rôles là
maintenant c'est une sorte de
bénédiction si vous voulez moi je suis
ravi de faire ça dans ce très joli qui
vont passer dans le monde de ce moment
la vie ce soir donner au public une
heure et demie de fable ii contre
quelque chose de
rim de soigner c'est un moment un
dernier mot vous avez si je suis bien
enseigner un projet de don quichotte que
vous aurez que vous produirez vous
battre francis chaubet yes déprimé mais
nous avons de gros problèmes de d'abord
d'avoir un bon scénario c'est pas facile
sur un classique
d'autre part il faut trouver un âne nous
allons en profiter pour lancer une
petite annonce un chéneau
téléspectateurs campagne à merci
beaucoup et terrance merci bottes donc
je rappelle la sortie de votre film
petit papa baston le 14 décembre sur nos
écrans juste avant noël merci beaucoup
pour ce conte de noël au far west
dernière nouvelle de ce